it's basically a surve have you ever had
a religious experience what do you mean
by that um um it could be you had a set
of a divine presence it could hear a
sense of a divine presence it could be
hearing the voice of God it could be
out could be it could be of divine peace
Divine Tranquility yeah of course could
be Dreams yeah of course we have this in
Islam but we don't have this here in the
words of God because why we have which
we
call Tiding sometimes you see which we
call not dream you know it could be like
a vision of some sort Vision yeah or
something which is from God you know yes
like for example I went through my life
and how God saved me to me it's very
like it's very like what they call it um
significant special significant special
events happen to me that which but a but
this a personal experience
truth every but some some people kind
collected experiences of the same thing
some Kindle to two Muslims they both
they heard the voice of of Angel
together yeah but again how do they know
he was
angw very very extremely beautiful
voice know there was no one else around
sometimes yes you can be directed or
being inspired or helped by the the
Angels but I never heard someone saying
heard the voice of the Angels you know
cuz again if it's a good thing Allah
knows best but again Satan can deceive
us for example now we go back to for
example the best example that I can give
you about uh e we can for into deception
and Satan Trap by believing that God SP
us directly Paul Paul he said on his way
I don't have story is true or not but
according to him God appeared to him
Jesus Jesus appeared to him yeah and in
the question how can he know that was
Jesus or not
pred I mean there's many prediction that
Paul said it didn't come true said that
Jesus The Voice told him go to an you'll
be healed there and and he went there
and thing Happ according to according to
Matthew 24:24 doesn't not prove that is
God speaking to you but according to
Matthew 24:24 even the Liars they would
do wonders Miracles they will have
Miracles so according to to Jesus
himself he said he said there will be
many liars okay deceivers and they will
have wonders wonders which mean Miracles
so because because for example fortune
tell from the S can tell you something
which is true about the future and our
Prophet told us but it's mixed with a
lot of for Prophet Muhammad told us how
Satan or the demon the Jin steal the
information or the news from the heaven
and pass it to one another until reaches
the the magician or the fortune then the
fortune himself mixes it mixes it
so that doesn't prove that Paul did hear
good because something happed and there
was prediction that occurred and took
place you understand so again like you
know so your master is about people the
way people having religious spiritual
mystical experiences and to what exent
can you indicate existence what we say
to about your own self because you know
the beaut of Islam teaches you to save
yourself first cuz you know you know
guarantee you and I all of us here we're
not guaranteed to live
forever yeah I mean we can we can die
any time you understand and we we going
to stand before God God is going to ask
you he going to tell you what do you
think about other people he's going to
ask you first that's in the Quran
says all who you believe save yourself
and your family from the
fire so you come in here say I don't
want to comment something which is wise
to
do it's wise
not to speak without I would say it's
wise not to come to decision until you
until you evalate all the evidence it
come to you done research and then come
to I don't make a claim and like 5 we
later understand where you coming from
you're right and even that Islam teaches
us to speak with knowledge however the
things that I'm speaking about don't
have a I I don't want to speak about but
what I we say to you the things that we
speak like me personally when I speak to
Christian
I don't go in detail generally speaking
maybe I do but generally speaking I
don't go in detail with a Christian lay
man about manuscripts about many
technical things what I do I speak about
something which is not by necessity for
example God becoming a human that
doesn't make any sense to any human
being because God is
perfect by him by God becoming a human
being by default he's going to become
imperfect which go God's nature is
perfect the being devil being devil what
do you think the contention is some CHR
would say the Jesus nature as God is
distinct from his nature as a human
being they're United in the same person
but they like your physical nature is
distinct from your spiritual nature
they're still United in the same so so
Jesus Is God nature it's distinct from
his human human nature by United in the
same person just how like your physical
nature is distinct from your spiritual
nature you're still United in the one
person how do you answer that it is easy
to to respond because when you ask them
tell me where which God which Jesus
nature is God within him and which one
for example the soul the soul is inside
me okay I mean me and the soul is the
same thing okay like when you say Shi if
you hurt me you're going to hurt me and
you HT my sh yes so it doesn't make any
sense Jesus had two natur within him
that doesn't make any sense it's a
contradiction understand brother that's
why even the Bible where Jesus said had
God nature and human nature at same time
he never said that he never said that
also uh uh uh there's not way to refuse
also okay I asked them if God was inside
Jesus okay which God was he the
Father the Son they said the son so the
son became human being because Accord
the Bible he said in the beginning was
the word and the Word was with God and
the word became flesh became okay became
flesh also that go in in the in the Old
Testament Jacob said to God the heavens
cannot contain you the heavens cannot
contain you let alone my own Temple so
if the heavens canot contain God why
because what is the greatest okay
because God because the Christian
sometimes nothing can contain him yeah
sorry no creation can contain him no
doubt uh the Christians they believe in
God conceptually not in reality God
exists independently he has own
attributes so so if no doubt the heavens
is greater and bigger than humans Jesus
body so how God was inside the body if
someone says yeah but you as a Muslim
say I can help you or have the
Christians in a way I have them but I
can refat some doubt because for example
they say yeah but when you say God
descends to the lowest Heaven you say
without how no there's differ between
something we can observe in our physical
word world and there's something which
is a pure and sin we can observe from
the phys physical word word word that he
Jesus he was a human being people they
saw him with their own eyes they didn't
say he was bigger than other human
beings he was a normal human being he
was ignorant he was mean ignorant
meaning he didn't know many things okay
uh disrespect Jesus as a Muslim if I do
disrespect Jesus Take No that become
disbeliever the point here is logically
speaking rationally how Jesus as human
being his body contained God which in
the Bible say the heavens canot contain
him I God go and get his nature to be
the Great
and became smaller than Jesus and there
were other human beings that were bigger
than Jesus so they were bigger than who
bigger than God who inside Jesus that
doesn't make any sense that's why in the
Quran you know the best example the
reputation against Christianity in the
Quran Allah said about Jesus and his
Mary both them used to eat food what
does that mean means that they cannot be
independent and God is independent is
self-sufficient if God's in need of food
cannot be self-sufficient
self-sufficient you know that's why ask
to Christians I always emphasize on the
most important thing which all human
beings share which is our sound
intellect you understand God become a
baby okay so when he was a baby I mean
you can correct me I I know that
Christians they say even when he was a
baby God was inside him God was God was
fully the baby God the baby the human AG
is distinct from God the baby and God
was fully United yes so God was inside F
the baby yeah was inside the baby so
again so Mary was bigger than
God Mary was bigger than God in size I
mean because God exist independently and
the heavens and earth can't contain him
I mean the Bible says that and in the
Quran of
course I'm doing anime philosophy so I'm
saying God I I do say religion I've read
all the religious Texs but you hav read
books Quran yeah yeah you have Quran
yeah yeah and correctly or just
newspaper no no I I read I read the
Quran I read most of sahkari I read I
read most of the Bible and Torah so some
understand what the religion say
right like one time read the I read the
many times
okay
from oh
no not NE what I hold it but I say from
for and a philosophical point of view
and and God from a philal point of view
is outside space it's outside
time okay when you say space and time
again here look this a prise and a
philosophy which Christianity adopted
later on Jesus many Muslims likewise I
agree yes so Jewish people did first
okay then the Christians follow them
then the Muslims did follow them you're
right so the point here is Jesus and
Moses and all the prophets and
Messengers they never came with
philosophy they came with logical Ral
philosophical defining
logic religious scripture might use and
what philosoph might they use same
relistic for for example for example
like talking about space and time yes we
talk about space and time again space is
ambiguous term all right because we so
God existed before the creation correct
yeah so when God created the creation
either he created the creation within
himself or outside him which one is it
so theal Fe say he created from nothing
no no no I'm not talking about from when
God created The Creation with within
himself or outside his himself if God
has no place inside outside like it
doesn't really no meaning but there is
God exists before the creation correct
yeah so now rationality God exists and
there's nothing beside God God created
the creation
yeah either is going to be inside
himself or outside him there's no
there's no third
option it's like it's like asking where
the edge of the Earth is
right the question it over here or over
there like no no no no okay is a logical
rational you cannot Escape it they know
the to something else God existed all
the time has not beginning correct yes
but but just saying God exist doesn't
mean God exist in a place two different
things I'm asking about place but but
then you ask inside him or outside him
so you when you ask that question did
God create the creation inside himself
outside himself you then presuppose God
exist in some type of
place yes but that does not doesn't
indicate okay okay even this physical
you see this this The Poon philosophy
you know everyone here I ask him because
they haven't philosophy naturally the
way God create us they say yes God
existed we have God cuz remember I said
to differentiate between conceptual
belief of God which only it is in your
mind do is in reality and that's the
majority of the belief the philosophers
Muslims or Christian or Jewish they have
God that only EX in their minds does in
reality but if God do God exist
independently independently all right
and he has
Essence okay he has the essence so
therefore God has the essence so when
God's going to create another creation
that creation doesn't exist out inside
him or inside him because there's only
God now but again you you're
presupposing EX in place no but no but
like like it's like me asking you which
swi swimming pool did you go to which
it's like me asking you which swimming
pool did you go to this morning swiming
pool yes I want hold on hold on if I ask
if I ask you right now which swiming
pool did you go to do this morning you
would say that that question presupposes
I went to a swimming pool but I never
went to
a a false comparison compar
but there's there's an assumption in
your question create the creation yes
but I'm asking you this go create the
creation that creation exist outside of
God God creating the creation do that
necess God must exist in a place to
create
the you're focus on outside and inside I
have focus on because God exists okay
yes okay God exists there's nothing
beside God God created the creat
all
right was
it
so right they all say God created from
nothing okay no no no no you're not
asking my question you ask a question I
never ask I'm asking you where did God
create the creation from I'm asking you
imagine give you example okay nothing
exist except me if going to create
something if nothing exist except me
either I'm going to create in me cuz
there's nothing there there's nothing
there beside me correct either I'm going
to create it inside me or outside me of
the and by the way this this is argument
of mentioned it and mentioned it okay
you can go back to it this is this the
the problem and the poison of philosophy
you start going you become what you do
in all respect you
become you can say you can you can have
that that you I'm just speaking nonsense
right
that many Muslim theologians EX
that's your view that's you you can have
that you can have that view you can have
that this is the people with sound
intellect one Muslim tells you something
other
Muslim I have to go back I have to go
back to what seems most like logical to
me right it seems for being that exists
before space and time talking about this
being had a place an outside inside
doesn't seem to be rationally warrant
where he created creation sorry where he
created The Creation The Creation does
the creation exist does exist does God
exist Does the exist inside him or
outside him has a place if God exist are
you playing around if ex there is
an if if there's nothing exist except me
there's nothing ex except me that's the
case I can't prove that I can't prove
that you believe in God yes okay and now
okay no problem you know what for all of
this if the uh uh God does doesn't have
Place according to
Bible just rationally just rationally
rationally have to ese the
Bible the term place is ambiguous if you
mean physical place which is created yes
I do you but if you mean God if you mean
God separated from this creation then it
has to be somewhere you call it place or
not up to you so we've agreed God does
not exist in a physical place and
therefore listen to my
words created no no wait wait wait you
put words in your mouth I don't believe
God is contained by physical place okay
however in the Bible and in the Quran
teaching according
to according to MOS and Jesus Jesus
according to the Bible Jesus is standing
next to God and God is sitting on the
front the front Okay is is the thr no
it's not in Corinthians it's in
Corinthians that's a reality on the day
of judgment God will be SE on the throne
yes
the afon is inside God or outside
god
well I'm not looked at these passages
the Bible I can show you that's why you
following a philosopher you're not
following
Jesus philosophy it comes from Genesis
because man because in Genesis it says
man was made in the image of God there's
an inherent mystery within Jewish and
Christian theology in that man the man's
making himself and man's sorry I don't
want to be filmed I'm all right
let's
agree we both agree God does not exist
in a physical place so so if we both
agree there contained by physical place
however
I so there's no point in talking about a
physical outside and an inside when you
say Outside Inside I only know
that's me
that
matter the only con outside and inside I
have in my head is not physical right
again the only con Outside Inside I have
in my head is not physical it's your
problem your mind's problem the reality
the problem your your problem upon
us no problem no problem we can only
only have my mind understand you
understand I have your mind I don't have
his sound reasoning which sound reason
if God does not exist in a physical
Place how can you physical Place how can
you speak of an outside and inside when
the only cont of Outside Inside I have
are physical what you phys who plays
something that has matter something that
has at have do have matter yeah
something has a matter okay so matter is
created of course so go outside the
matter okay God is Not created okay
that's that's what I said to you if God
exist independently yeah God ex
independently correct yeah it's not did
he create a creation yes okay it is
creation with inside gold outside God no
no why if there is God independently
exists he has own Essence yes
I is a logical rational outcome you
cannot turn away from it you need create
the creation not from where when he
create the
creation when he create the creation
outside him inside him cuz he exist
independently okay or he's above the
creation or the creation above him or
because he created in
reality me if you mean if you mean
outside in the that if you mean outside
by by the
creation the creation is distinct from
God that yes that's
it hold on primarily outside mean
place no no no no no no this again again
this the problem of being point with
philosophy because philosophy Tred to
dictate us for example if you say this
therefore you mean that yeah if you say
this it has to be this
way for example if something moves must
have a body okay this a philosophical
conclusion we're talking about God we're
not talking about this again that's what
I said to you a differentiate between
followers of Jesus and Moses and the
followers of philosophers the Christians
now they don't follow Jesus and Moses
anymore but they don't even follow Moses
I mean even Jewish even some Muslims
they when it comes in speaking about
God's Essence they speak with the
terminology of the philosophers so God
is distinct from his creation
correct that's that's what I say and
therefore God that's why we say God is
above the creation distin from his
creation so therefore the creation exist
independently and God exist
independently yeah you agree yeah that's
it and this why he go with the CU When
he say no it's inside him outside him so
has to physically speaking is physical
dubious
ambiguous inside and outside physical
referen again again why I to look this
you have to be careful when we say
physical I don't care what this
philosoph going say no okay is this
creation matter God created it is he
mixed with it no it's distinct from it
so it's outside him and he distinct from
his being yet if he
distinct speak meing again repeat
again that's what Outside Inside Outside
Inside refer to places that's what it
primar means is God distinct from the
creation yes so it's outside him if by
being distinct in that sense yes that's
not the that is not the
primary that's not the primary mean of
outside me finish so therefore God being
outside the creation doesn't mean God is
in a place which
we so we as a Muslim and cies that's why
you
know they believe which yourself now you
start dropping CU it's distinct
which therefore necessitate outside
him distinct of go mean
is me together let me ask
question words have
meaning Christians I
understand from the
universe has
Oneal mean
right think God is outside the creation
you have two possible
right
why why why you focus on the more
ambiguous way of saying it when a more
unequal way of
saying one une
mean you outside how
theide no no no no no no
outside
necessitate distinct cuz if something is
distinct if I'm distinct from something
El with me or outside me in the of
being you the of being you God is
outside God is a being but is a being
yes outside the creation in a secondary
sense yes but that's not the prim of the
word outside so why F so why
would primarily outside first right no
not all the time primarily
no no no we about creation no no no no
we need talk about creation therefore if
I'm talking about God I'm being so clear
because
dict if God is the only has no beginning
end and there was no creation so there
will be no physical place which mean
create when I say physical mean I like
emphasize mean create the place because
there was nothing
create had not begin so therefore when
God created the creation which is it
must have a place therefore when we say
God has a if you mean God is outside the
creation I said yes and you agree with
me separate from his creation that's why
agree with
that outside he's not inside he not the
right the left but even that even that
that's him he came with argument which
isical Ral any human being that's why I
said to you I
emphasizing
independently philosoph Christians
Christians I've noticed when they start
speaking about gods they focus more on a
conceptual concept of conceptual Gods
which only in the head because doesn't
make any sense exist independently and
is not
separated I read read right where the
day of judgment he will first interview
the Jews and then the Christians and
they will come to the Muslims right the
right and unri them and he will come to
the in the that isos to
them no
no that on the day of judgment Allah
will appear in one form and appear
another form yes but that doesn't mean
he got against nature again understand
so our my concept of God and your
concept of God might be different but we
can't say our mine or your concept of
God is represent encapsulate the nature
of God because one be our our
comprehension and two the itself said
God will come in the
form come to us suggesting we cannot
truly I don't know if I
remember ex the exact was iari I can
bring it next week translation maybe the
wrong
translation the world was versus the
picture of him in the in in their mind
right no there's no say close pictures
in our mind anyway the point here
is a few days ago you can get
translation Allah will come in one form
then you will come in another form as it
say yes I do we not comprehend
everything about God likewise we don't
comprehend his true nature but we
understand certain things which God sent
us about himself there we understand
like which
call Universal knowledge or that which
is not by necessity for
example when we speak about God's
attributes they try to negate Go's
attribute if you do a firit you are
resembling God to his creation which is
incorrect okay because for example the
argument that used against them if you
saying ifms attribute of God for God
therefore I'm res his creation you you
are a life God is a life is your life
like God's life no okay likewise for
every attribute and
every name of God same criteria you
understand so for example like I said to
you about um when go that's why
the uh I don't give me a fake name
anyway I'm the hom by the way okay okay
okay my middle name is Hass
go mid my name
why we say to you that's why in the
beginning I to you the Christians now
they follow the
Christian like you said some Muslim well
if you listen to Bob Bob is not speaking
how Jesus spoke about God he speaking
about how Christian fathers who were
heavily influenced by Greek philosophy
speak about God I'm not sure once I was
speaking to a Jewish a young boy and he
negate every attribute of God like a
you understand which doesn't make any
sense so the good they believe in
doesn't exist in the reality because
anything that exists in the reality
independently must have attributes you
understand so that's my arum but let me
bring you back you know after you
digress a lot the point here is about
Christianity God doesn't make any sense
the concept of God I mean becoming a
baby and I would say Christian concept
of God Prim about about the Trinity okay
how there's three distinct person
they are one still one God they are one
in what if there are well the question
AR is one
in the same essence or same self or so
for
example sh Hass Jamal we are distinct
people but we are one Essence cuz you
have human same thing exactly okay so
now if Jesus Is God by default God has
not beg to end and he has everything
perfect okay everything perfect okay and
God does not submit to No One you agree
everything submit to God the Christian
they say to us yes when Jesus was on the
earth he had to pretend or act like a
human being yeah humble himself humble
himself yeah which doesn't make any
sense that's not God's nature that's
human nature humble himself God does not
need to Humble to no one because he's
the greatest guess what in Paul which
cores yeah on the day on the day of
judgment everything will submit to Jesus
then Jesus himself will submit to the
father he'll be
subordinate sub submit subjugate worship
so you just told me God has not submit
to no one if Jesus Is God and that is
not on the day of judgment not only he
human being on a day of judgment he's
going submit to the father therefore
they're not same Jesus is lower than the
father I mean yeah I guess like what
what they would say what they would say
would say human even when he's God the
human nature is still distinct from his
div they United in person but no but
they say when he returned
they when he return he's not human
anymore he's God no he's both human even
when even when he returns so it's going
to be going to be human always going to
be fully human fully God H they said the
reason he became human here to
communicate with us that when he went
back to the day of judgment way he
resurrected he resurrected and human
also resurrect and human resurrect part
a human nature Jesus resurrect as a
human as well but in the Bible does it
not say Jesus human nature submit to God
he said Jesus himself so himself as a
whole that include God's nature
according to your belief and the
question also Jesus as God is he the
father no he not the father Jesus as God
does he know the hour no huh no do no so
you Cann be good yeah that's a problem
yeah Jes as God is is Jesus as God what
I've seen in the in the Bible Jes cuz
God is not good part time it's good all
the time you should be worshiped the
Lord should be glorified right in the
Bible seems that Jesus as God he's like
he took day off to be God just Jesus
worshiping the father only only the
father only the father he's not even
asking his other nature which is God to
help him that's why look Islamic
teaching which goes in line with our
sound intellect and the natural
imination which the Creator create us
with that's why the Creator is the most
wise when he created you and I and
everyone he create with us the TOs and
vies which go in line with the
Revelation that's why God is one is
perfect he has no beginning no end Jesus
will love him he's a mighty messenger
and this a dirty uh uh not all the
French people but the Olympics what they
did to uh uh disrespecting Jesus the
disciples and the dinner and the B free
from it and this is satanic way and we
Muslim would defend Jesus you know but
clearly Jesus and all the prophet
Messengers came to call people to
worship one God and stay away from the
Satan okay and that is an Islamic
teaching that's why you know one the
Miracle of Islam which me myself I like
to use h a lot one of the so powerful
prophecy you know that the enemies of
Islam okay they have stronger weapons
than the Muslims
uh the opponents in the beginning yes
and now now yeah now like for example
when it comes to social media it's
controlled by the just what happened
recently what happened recently the riot
social media was utilized by the of
Islam even the guy who committed the
crime he was a Christian he has nothing
to do with Islam yet they were attacking
the most so the point here I was going
to bring I want to bring you back to is
there's a verse in the Quran Allah
said it's Allah who sent Prophet
Muhammad with a true religion in order
to prev other religions even if it
disbeliever is like it now even there
the the the Islamic opponents they have
stronger weapons social media and so on
the fast grow which can cause many
barriers to stop people accept Islam yet
the fastest growing religion in the
Western World specifically where they
say we oppress women where they say the
Islam is bad and everything Islam is
spreading and there was study carried
out about the British women they study
Islam for five years then they accept
Islam there is a powerful Prophecy in
the Quran okay okay good for them um but
why for you
to you become he's on a no comment he's
he's on a no commenting no comment
baile I I I no com it comes to my right
anyway what say to you this is again
even this what you doing now no comments
yeah I don't want speak all of this it
came from
who come from you iamp I know I'm finite
my mind is finite I don't know
everything okay so when I'm presenting
with variety of views right I have to
make sure I'm thly well researched
anding them to make stop making Juds
because if I stop speaking I'm could
mislead people I I could information
that's why I like to keep things like
conser I respect for that but what we
talking about Hass we talking that which
is now by necessity I never want you to
look let's talk about the Bible the
manuscript the the and so no that's why
I said to you when I speak to the
Christians I will never genely speaking
to the lay and Christians I I don't
speak about detail issues why I speak
about that which is known by necessity
which is the Oneness of Allah the oness
of Allah is clear and pure in everything
the concept of Islam is so clear there's
only one God yes he has attribut a
perfect attribute he sent the prophets
and Messengers to call people to worship
God alone okay that's why when you have
out experience and before before I want
to bring you back to the issue of I
don't make no comments again this is the
Western Academy has been wed by Greek
philosophy which they always I want to I
don't want to no you make Jesus he never
said what you said I don't want to make
comments
no why you say that no no I don't say
Allah one no no no no I don't
say I know his I know for certainty
certain things say Allah no certain
things which we there
is room for doubt that we say understand
I say
is Allah told
you you know so the point here is that
you should think about yourself like I
said to you reflect upon situation
because like I said to remind you when
you die none of this Western Academy
Academy Academic Way of yeah I don't
want to take no position I don't want to
say I have to do the truth or the false
but do you
resarch take my survey yeah okay
give a pen oh you're going to give me
the actual
paper has yeah
yeah I can give you a nice book come who
is bring the a I can give you a nice
book and I can give it to your sister as
well cuz you want to give us help us I
can give it to read as well it's a nice
book that you can read I mean you can
read this shows Islam
us two two two
two and we have it I'm going to show
people to the Muslims you can come to
our
table you can come to our because even
the Muslim should read it it's very very
beneficial very beneficial Muslim to
read it and to to learn from it and to
give I'm going to take it or you f it
out and bring it back to I I have to
fill it are
you this a home office you the home
office are you secret
agent sign your I'm not going to come in
this week after two weeks or weeks I'll
be the
show yes how are you man you're right
how you doing